you are the executive producer uh or an  executive for great gig on Santa Clair  diet tell me what your what are you  responsibilities there nothing that's  the it's the best job in the world  everybody most people in Hollywood know  this if anyone comes up to you and says  they're Hollywood producer it sounds  great but really it means this is good  chance they do nothing just cashing the  checks yeah it's it's true it's uh it's  oh I hear you it's like a volunteer  position yeah it really is  yeah it's like there's int there's  executive producer and then there's  intern above that I think yeah exactly  that's sort of how it feels yeah the  producer is like it's just good that I'm  here yeah that's kind of the vibe well  you know who's not that's not your all  day you know what it's not true of our  executive producer mr. Jeff Ross that  guy  [Music]  the way no no it looks  you